in other news the congressional
investigation into the assault on the
capitol is revealing more evidence
handed over by former white house chief
of staff mark meadows he is now refusing
to cooperate with the committee and
members voted last night to pursue
charges of contempt of congress we know
that at the height of the january 6
attack fox news host and donald trump jr
pleaded with medals to get
then-president trump to stop the riot
the co killian is on capitol hill with
response from the former chief of staff
nicole good morning hey good morning to
you nate mark meadows calls the contempt
vote disappointing but not surprising he
said he tried to cooperate and claims
this is all about going after former
president trump
when you look at
the criminal component of this the
intent there's never been an intent on
my part former chief of staff mark
meadows appeared on a familiar platform
to defend his and former president
trump's actions on january 6. i think at
the end of the day
they're going they're going to find that
that not only did the president act but
he acted quickly but during his
appearance last night on fox news with
host sean hannity there was little
mention of new revelations from the 9
000 pages of documents he turned over
including text messages between himself
and a number of cable tv hosts during
the attack in one text exchange hannity
urged meadows to tell mr trump to quote
make a statement and ask people to leave
the capitol host laura ingram also
pleaded with meadows mark the president
needs to tell people in the capitol to
go home she added he is destroying his
legacy
and even the president's son don jr
wrote to meadows in a text message he's
got to condemn this asap the capitol
police tweet is not enough meadows
responded i am pushing it hard
these text messages leave no doubt
the white house knew exactly what was
happening here at the capitol
members of congress the press and others
wrote to mark meadows as the attack was
underway the committee also points to an
email between meadows and an unnamed
individual on january 5th it said the
national guard would be present to quote
protect pro-trump people what did you
make of that text was there an effort to
simply protect the supporters of the
president even those who were attacking
the capitol after refusing to answer
questions those in favor say aye
aye
for the first time the house select
committee investigating january 6
rebuked one of its own recommending
contempt charges for meadows a former
congressman himself whatever legacy he
thought he left in the house
this is his legacy now
his former colleague singing him out
for criminal prosecution
the committee and meadows have been
battling for months he is now the third
person the committee has referred for
contempt the full house is expected to
vote later today and if it passes it
would be referred to the justice
department which will ultimately decide
whether to press criminal charges gail
those text messages very revealing thank
you very much nicole